-Our next guest has
her comedy album, "Perm Day,"
available at MaryMackComedy.com.
Please welcome the very funny
Mary Mack.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, Jimmy!
Hey, guys!
Thank you!
Oh, man.
Thanks!
Thank you so much!
I -- I am Mary Mack.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
Guys, I was so excited
to be here, I put on makeup.
[ Laughter ]
I know. They say you
gotta blend it in.
I'm not blending it in.
I want to get somewhere and have
people be like, "She tried."
[ Laughter ]
Right?
It's hard to age as a woman.
I got -- I got a mole
on my face now,
keeps sprouting out a hair.
I cut it, it sprouts,
I cut it, it sprouts.
I can't keep up.
It's like mowing the yard.
All right?
Yeah.
I'm thinking about getting
a neighbor kid to cut it.
[ Laughter ]
I grew up in Northern Wisconsin.
Yeah.
Not fancy, yeah.
We -- We didn't -- We didn't get
a spring break in school.
Instead, we got a week off
in November for deer hunting.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, 'cause with a freezer
full of venison,
who cares if you graduate?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Chuckles ]
One time in school,
the teacher's decided to have
a "healthy lifestyles day."
It's never been attempted
before or since
in the state of Wisconsin.
[ Laughter ]
But I took a class.
It was called
"How to slow your breathing down
in case you fall through
the ice."
[ Laughter ]
But it wasn't even taught by,
like, a expert or a park ranger.
It was just some guy
who fell through the ice...
[ Laughter ]
...and figured it out.
My mom is retired up there
in the woods,
and she has no Internet
or cable news,
so she has to have
her own thoughts.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
My mom is pro-trans rights,
and she enjoys burning plastic.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
You can't pigeon-hole Jan.
You can't.
[ Laughter ]
My mom is from that very bland
Scandinavian country
called Duluth, Minnesota.
You ever --
Oh, good.
Yeah, yeah.
She's never even
had yogurt before.
Mnh-mnh.
Too spicy.
[ Laughter ]
She's working with
an old Swedish taste palate.
"Oh, chives on a baked potato?
What, are they trying
to kill me?"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, there's a lot of heat in
a -- it can sneak up on you.
Okay? Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Chives are like the habanero
of Minnesota, all right?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Anyway, my whole family, they're
so much tougher than I am.
I got one brother, Scott.
He got ran over by the bulldozer
a few years ago.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
No, he's fine.
He's fine.
[ Laughter ]
He's almost more normal now.
Yeah, yeah.
But think about that.
The bulldozer,
that doesn't have wheels.
That has tracks.
Tracks!
So it takes a long time
to get ran over by it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah.
You got to be patient.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Not me.
I'm not tough.
I -- the toughest thing
I ever did was,
I ate organic food last week.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the whole week.
Oh, man.
I had organic maple bacon fudge.
Do you ever --
you ever have organic maple --
it's hard to get it organic.
Pbht!
There's a lot of layers.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah? Yeah.
The fudge, that's got to be,
like, cage-free or something.
[ Laughter ]
Most people like
to pre-package their fudge.
That is not a euphemism.
That is a USDA regulation.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then you got the bacon.
That --
oh, think about the pig.
The pig has to be like,
"Oh, okay, fine."
The pig has to give consent.
Otherwise, it's not organic.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Yeah, that pig
has a safe word, too.
If he oinks twice
before the conveyor belt,
he gets to go to a community
college of his choice.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Little too weird.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Before I go, I just want
to let you know about a service
I'm offering.
You can see me -- if you're
having problems sleeping,
come see me after the show.
What I do,
I rent my husband out to you.
He comes over,
stands next to your bed,
and tells you about
his fantasy-football team
for a while.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Five minutes, and you're out.
I'm almost med-free!
Yeah!
Thank you so much!
I'm Mary Mack!
Happy holidays!
-Almost med-free?
Almost?
[ Laughter ]
Mary Mack, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's exactly right.
Check out "Perm Day"
at MaryMackComedy.com.
We'll be right back,
ladies and gentlemen.